hello I'm Weird Al Yankovic and this is  my FIT check I'm wearing this Ensemble  because I just got off the road six  months on the road and I just pulled  this off the bus and it's my stage  closed like I always wear a Hawaiian  shirt and this is not really Hawaiian  per se but yeah close enough I got the  shirt out of my closet or I keep all my  shirts and the black slacks and uh you  know a lot of November bands but I you  know the Drew show demanded some respect  I'm wearing my dress shoes for the show  people ask me what hair products I use I  I don't really have brand loyalty I just  use whatever's in the shower so I am I  don't know my hair just grows out of my  head like this I can't help it  this is this is my Ensemble I hope you  enjoy it